let's have a look at one so i will point
out the first one we actually have a
correct answer for I believe a different
question so I'm gonna also want to shout
out what their and with a hand up what's
their answer for number one someone
opens up cushion 4318 hands up if you
agree what do you think okay thank you
hear that um by the way how did i know
because i was working at this 4699 and I
thought texting about the right ballpark
how do you know without touching a
pencil that something's gone wrong how
do we know that that's actually the
answer different questions yanika okay
so if you just think about something
really simple right you're at four and
seven there that's what you're going to
get the units from isn't it the H right
so I know I'm going to end on eight
whatever the rest of it is going to be
another way you can know is 34 is an
even number right it's an even number
you multiply anything by an even number
if its hole and you're going to get
another up even number at the other end
yeah these are little things you can do
so you can make sure okay so get the
right answer or not you can check okay
all right people happy with this one you
could check if you x 37 if you do get
that I'm reasonably confident in 292
depletion number two it hands up if you
think 31 remaining two looks good hands
up hands up straight oh I have a much
smaller number of hands up maybe what
I'll do is I'll ask you to raise your
hand if you did that question you felt
confident with it ends up straight yeah
about the same time okay hands down what
I want you to do it with your pen there
is let's walk through how we're going to
do this long division because long
division is a skill we looked at a while
ago maybe you forgot me that's okay 16
500 so want to give me a suggestion for
what they first very first thing that
they put on the page will be any
suggestions real yeah I'm going to put a
zero right in the front what does a
sierra signify what's it about ya tuhan
very good I can't fit any 16s into fire
and so I put that zero down to mean that
you guys know we don't just go through
these steps for any random reason or
because that's the steps that would go
through we want to know what every part
of it means ok what's going to happen
next someone else who hasn't said
anything yeah yeah [ __ ] what would you
put down ok how many times to 16 going
to 50 and 60 times tables not that
common but do you think yet again to
hold you would be three very good
because she can go 16 32 what's the next
one 48 and then you know you're not
going to fit in anymore ok so 48 I'm
going to write down here 316 now what
what eunuch eel ok i'm going to subtract
which gives me too we're doing well this
morning good job guys long weekend I've
almost there at the end Maria when we
gonna do next ok because just like at
the start no more 16 fit into our number
two I need to bring in 0 to increase the
times when over there you ok now what
what do I do here
okay wait Paula where you mean here
above here yeah okay and what does that
one signified any takers Daniel can you
tell me what that one's about it's a bit
trick is it yeah reddish going off not
yeah very good like each time I'm asking
how many times do I fitted you how many
times do I fit it in that's what
division is all about right and it fits
in once okay I'm pretty much there
aren't I what am I gonna do now yeah
turn 1 by 16 gives you 16 okay so you
can see I was very close with brick
we've got the important bit didn't we
sawed off that we know we can fit in 31
times and it's just that little bit in
the air but well done okay this last
week here what do you guys think of our
odd to hear x equals 67 who's happy with
that adds up yeah cool well done i'm
going to add here I think we should
include one extra thing but it says
giving reasons I think this is the
beginning this is the beginning of our
reason but I'd love to have another
thing on the end of the reason 28 angles
what yeah very good I guess that's two
more things and if you had your reasons
there I'd love you to finish that off
with me it's important we have all of
those pieces they're currently angles
are supplementary on parallel lines you
really need all three of them don't you
you need to know their co interior how
do they relate to each other you want to
know they're supplementary they're not
equal that's an easy mistake to me and
none of this matters if the ones are
parallel I don't have any names I don't
come up maybe you'll see the area like
that so we just stayed